we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
uh we had a discussion the other day
about what i call the smoked salmon
bagel index it's like my version of the
big mac or the whopper index where i go
okay like what's a smoked salmon bagel
cost in different places and the egg man
wrote in with what is quite frankly not
a good suggestion take a listen to this
or he called in rather
hey dave i have a question about the
smoked salmon bagel index please in
western new york where i live you can
buy the um smoked salmon cream cheese
spread it's like
cream cheese and lox spread mixed
against that pink cream cheese right and
then you put that on a bagel it's like
having smoked salmon
and cream cheese on your bagel right
yeah you know i mean listen i think
everybody should have whatever they want
i reject the notion and i reject it
wholeheartedly that is a freaking
predator right there yes that uh the the
the pink cream cheese that has some
smoked salmon kind of uh
blended into it
is the same as properly putting smoked
salmon on the bagel it's it's just i
can't and i know we're getting very deep
into jewish cuisine here
it's a really tough uh i'm not gonna die
on this hill but it's a tough thing for
me to accept
you get one of those for like a couple
of bucks
is that good enough for you or do you
actually need the actual smoked salmon
and the capers all that stuff for
17 11 bucks
shalom brother yeah i mean listen i'm
not a buyer at 17 bucks for a smoked
salmon bagel
but uh at prices south of that you'll
certainly find me find me considering it
but no listen uh honestly that that
smoked salmon cream cheese
it's not bad it's not bad it's just a
whole different thing it's a completely
different element and i think everybody
should be aware of that we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today by
the way how many people will be mad
because they are taking the smoked
salmon
segment seriously
unfortunately probably dozens that's a
sad it's a sad thing on today's bonus
show
insurrectionist senator josh hawley
is introducing a measure to strip disney
of copyright protections
these people with their hypocrisy they
love copyright protections they want
patent protection forever for
pharmaceuticals and all this stuff oh
disney doesn't like the don't say gay
bill strip them of copyright protection
josh hawley horrible person we'll talk
about that there is a bill
that will help women pay to travel to
california
for abortions if needed
the bill is moving forward we are going
to talk about that and also after this
viral video of boxer mike tyson
showed him
punching an airline passenger
uh he is not going to be charged for
that and we will talk about why and what
the different elements of that legal
decision are
all on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com i can't wait to see you
on today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad if alex jones doesn't like it
you can be damn sure that you probably
will you can use the coupon code obama
to get a discount off of your choice of
membership at joinpakman.com you must
spell it correctly it's like correctly
incorrectly
[Music]
and you'll get a great discount we'll
see you on the bonus show